BILL LIVE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS,
THANKS VERY MUCH.
FOR MORE ON THE CRISIS AT
SOUTHERN BORDER WE ARE JOINED BY
TEXAS REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN AND
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE KEVIN BRADY.
CONGRESSMAN, WELCOME.
>> THANKS, MIKE, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
MIKE: ALL INDICATION THAT THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER HAS NOT
GOTTEN BETTER.
IS IT SOMETIME FOR SOMEONE
HIGH-RANKING IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO RESIGN?
>> YOU KNOW, I WOULD THINK IT’S
BEYOND THAT TIME.
LOOK, THIS IS ALL PREDICTABLE.
WE SAID THIS FOR MONTHS, THE
SITUATION IN THE BORDER IS NOT
GETTING BETTER BUT GETTING WORSE
AND WHEN YOU VISIT WITH THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS THEY’VE
BEEN CRYING IT OUT FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS.
NOW WE ARE SEEING THAT HAPPENED.
NO ONE LED BY THIS PRESIDENT OR
VICE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO CARE
ABOUT THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
HERE, ABOUT THE DANGER OF THESE
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS ENTERING THE
U.S. AND SO FAR THEY’VE MANAGED
TO BY IGNORING IT APPARENTLY
AVOID THE RESPONSIBILITY BUT
WE’VE NEVER SEEN IT LIKE THIS IN
TEXAS, I DON’T THINK WE’VE EVER
SEEN FRANKLY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IT CAN’T CONTINUE.
MIKE: WE ARE SHOWING OUR VIEWERS
LIVE IMAGES OF THE SCENE UNDER
THE BRIDGE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS,
YOUR REACTION TO SEEING ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE, AN ESTIMATED
13,000 PEOPLE CAMPED OUT UNDER
THAT BRIDGE.
>> YEAH, IT IS -- IT’S STUNNING
AND IT’S DISHEARTENING AND IT
IS, AGAIN, REMINDS ME OF ALL THE
CHILDREN WE SAW CRAMMED INTO
THOSE DETENTION CENTERS EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
I WAS IN DEL RIO AND AT THE TIME
EVEN THOUGH IT WASN’T GETTING A
LOT OF ATTENTION YOU WERE
ALREADY SEEING AND HEARING FROM
THE MAYOR JUST A NUMBER OF
VEHICLE CHASES, THE PROPERTY
DAMAGE, THE RESIDENTS SCARED
ABOUT FRANKLY THEIR SAFETY IN A
TOWN THAT HADN’T BEEN AFFECTED
LIKE THIS BEFORE.
THIS WAS MONTHS AGO.
IT HAS ONLY WORSENED AND IT WILL
NOT GET ANY BETTER AND IT’S
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IGNORES THIS.
MIKE: HAITIANS MARKETS WILL BE
FLOWN BACK TO HAITI BUT THEY
OBVIOUSLY DIDN’T JUST WALK
ACROSS THE BORDER.
HAVE YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO
HOW THE HECK HAITIANS ARE
GETTING TO OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AND WHO IS BASICALLY RUNNING THE
SHOW?
>> YEAH, IT IS DIFFICULT TO
TELL, TWO THOUGHTS ONE THEY
DIDN’T COME -- THEY AREN’T
COMING BY ACCIDENT, CLEARLY THE
WORD IS OUT THAT IF -- THAT
THERE ARE OPEN BORDERS IN THE
U.S. AND THIS IS HOW YOU ACCESS
IT.
WHAT WE READ AND HEAR ABOUT,
THEIR SEEMS TO BE DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS THAT THE HAITIANS ARE
TAKING HERE TO GET TO THIS
BORDER.
NO ONE CLEAR PATH BUT NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT, THEY KNOW
THERE’S AN OPEN BORDER HERE,
THEY ARE WILLING TO RISK IT AND,
AGAIN, THIS IS ALL -- THESE ARE
DANGEROUS JOURNEYS ESPECIALLY
FOR YOUNG WOMEN AND YOUNG MEN
AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
PRESIDENT CAN IGNORE IT AN HOUR
LONGER.
MIKE: FUNDING RUNS OUT IN THE
END OF THE MONTH AND ALLOWING TO
RAISE THE DEBT CEILING.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE
POLITICAL CALCULATION ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER IS.
I PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
CLEAN VOTE ON A DEBT CEILING TO
REPUBLICANS ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO
ON THE RECORD ON THAT VOTE ONLY
AND NOT -- NOT MIX IT WITH A --
A FUNDING MEASURE BUT ULTIMATELY
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO
GET BOTH OF THEM DONE.
MIKE: DO YOU EXPECT SPEAKER
PELOSI TO COMBINE A FUNDING
EXPANSION AND GET INTO ONE
PACKAGE?
>> YEAH, I DO.
I THINK THEY ARE RAISING THE
STAKES IN A WAY THEY CAN SHUT
DOWN THIS GOVERNMENT AND I THINK
DO DAMAGE TO THE ECONOMY AT THE
SAME TIME.
II DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE
DOING THIS.
WHAT CHAIRMAN DIDN’T TALK ABOUT
WAS THAT DEMOCRATS HAVEN’T HAD
ONE CONVERSATION WITH ONE
REPUBLICAN ABOUT A PLAN, NOT
JUST TO RAISE THE DEBT SEALING
BUT TO GET OUR FINANCIAL HOUSE
IN ORDER.
THE EMERGENCY SPENDING FAR
BEYOND THE EMERGENCY WILL
CRIPPLE OUR FINANCES IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE FUTURE MUCH LESS
3 AND A HALF TRILLION DOLLARS
THAT THEY ARE PROPOSING AND AT
THIS POINT IT’S THE DEMOCRATS
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEY ARE
DOING THE SPENDING AND RUNNING
EVERYTHING IN A PARTISAN WAY.
IT’S THEIR JOB TO GET THIS DONE.
MIKE: TO THE 3 AND A HALF
TRILLION DOLLAR IN TAX PACKAGE,
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TAXES INCLUDED IN THE MASSIVE
SPENDING BILL?
>> YEAH, MOST AMERICANS THINK
THE COUNTRY IS ON THE WRONG
TRACK AND IT WILL KILL AMERICAN
JOBS, DRIVE PRICES UP EVEN
HIGHER ON FAMILIES AND I THINK
HOOK A NEW GENERATION, THE POOR
ON GOVERNMENT DEPEND GOVERNMENT
TILL UP TO 3 MILLION JOBS OVER
TIME AND DEVASTATING TAX HIKES
ON MAIN STREET SMALL BUSINESSES,
JUST AS TRYING TO COME OUT OF
COVID AND DOUBLED THE DEBT TAX,
NUMBER OF FAMILY-OWNED
BUSINESSES AND FINALLY PRESIDENT
BIDEN CLEARLY BREAKS HIS PLEDGE
BY RAISING TAXES ON LOW INCOME
AND MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES, DON’T
TAKE MY WORD FOR THAT.
BOTH THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
TAXATION AND THE LEFT-LEANING
POLICY CENTER SAYS TAX INCREASES
ON THE MIDDLE CLASS COULD START
AS EARLY AS NEXT YEAR.
MIKE: FASCINATE, KEVIN BRADY